[Music]
do
thank you everyone for having me here
today
i am really excited about css conf
so i've always been kind of stuck in the
middle because i'm not a very good
designer but i love css
and so i spent a lot of time doing
javascript and html5
but really there's so much to be learned
about css and there's so very few places
for people like us to go
to learn about it to share what we've
learned with each other so i'm excited
to be here today i'm excited to be
with all of you
my name is jeff bertoft and i work for
microsoft i'm an html5 evangelist which
means i get to go around and talk with
developers about html5 and how they
implement it and how it works with
internet explorer in windows 8 apps
today specifically i wanted to talk
about flexbox so i have kind of a love
hate relationship with flexbox which i'm
guessing that many of you do as well
but i want to start out with kind of a
definition of flexbox
and this is the definition i pulled from
this back it's quite boring and dry
and it says the children of a flex
container can be laid out in any
direction and can conflicts their sizes
either growing to fill unused space and
shrinking to avoid
and you get the idea you're probably
bored already i like to describe it as
this
it's parental control
so we have an element that has children
inside of it and we define rules on that
element and the children follow those
rules do i have any parents in the room
does anyone wish that they could have
css flexbox for their kids
i mean i wish i could get my kids to act
like i want them to and to follow the
rules instead they end up acting like me
and i can't figure out what i'm doing
wrong but
with css flexbox we have parental
control so we can define how we want
each of the children of an element to
behave
and if you start to think about the
power in that you realize what there is
to get excited about with flexbox
i can have an element
that just by changing some css
properties some flex properties on that
element can control and change the
behaviorist of his children depending on
the circumstances so we often think
about this for media queries and how
important it is when we have different
sizes of screens or different device
orientations and we want to lay out our
content differently
we can do that with flexbox
you know also think about localization
you know
we often think about how we read
and we go from left to right on the
screen
but there's different languages that
have completely different set of rules
on how they read text and flexbox
actually gives us the power to be able
to change based on what we know about
the person who's reading it so we have
parental control
now here comes the bad part
so flexbox does have a sorted history
so i'm going to take you all the way
back to 2009 the original flexbox spec
it was quite exciting
introduced and then by 2010 it was
already implemented in a number of
webkit browsers myself i was
specifically excited about seeing it
inside of webos it was one of the main
controls for laying out your apps in web
os
so as a webos developer at the time i
got real excited
dug into it and really learned how
flexbox
worked and the how to get the power out
of it
and then
i woke up one day and it was gone
the flexbox spec was just canceled they
had decided that it wasn't working out
it wasn't going to be interoperable it
wasn't going to translate across
browsers well
and that actually turned out to be a
good thing
because in 2011 a new modern spec was
developed
which actually had more power gave you
more flexibility
and was a lot easier to use
so we'll we'll talk about why this is
important in a minute but then in 2012
ie10 implemented the spec as it was and
then the spec changed a little bit more
so mostly it was syntax changes you know
we the way that we we state those
properties but it also added a few new
key features so that was good as well
but as developers what that leaves us
with
is with different browsers supporting
different versions of this same spec so
we have some older browsers that support
the 2009 spec ie 10 is supporting the
earlier implementation of the modern
spec
and
release candidate in browser versions
going forward are going to release the
support the final spec
so it can be difficult for us to utilize
but i'm hoping by the end of this to
encourage you all to want to use flexbox
in the future for your applications
so there's a lot of good there's a lot
of bad now
to
really demonstrate how flexbox works i
tried to figure out
kind of some of my favorite things that
i can use to put a demo together
so i thought
i love the brady bunch
and i love animated gifs so what could
go wrong right let's go to flexbox demo
out of that
so before i show you this demo i want to
tell you i had a really hard time
finally finding the models for this demo
so
i do think i ended up with some pretty
attractive models and at microsoft
uh we do have
you know availability to these high
quality models that maybe not all
companies do but i'm going to start out
and play the demo for you
here's the story
[Music]
the youngest one
[Applause]
[Music]
is
busy living all
[Music]
and they knew that it was much
that's the way we all became the brave
[Music]
all right hopefully that's a little bit
more fun
a little bit more fun than just some
boring blocks on the screen
now the key to this is that i didn't
change markup for any of that i didn't
change margins i didn't change paddings
i didn't change layouts the only thing
that i changed was flexbox properties
and then display so i could control
which of those boxes
were showing and which ones weren't so
just real quickly i'm going to show you
the code that went behind that it is
very simple
so all i had is a parent container
which is the screen area
and then divs with the animated gifs
inside of them so whenever we look at
the css we're really going to be looking
at the css that we apply to the screen
area because remember it is parental
control that we're looking at here
so to start out with mrs brady
what we actually did
is
um
and let me stop for a sec what i'm going
to show you on the the side of the
screen here with the css the top is
going to be the ms prefix that i'm using
remember i talked about the earlier
version of the spec that was implemented
because that's what i use for this demo
running ie10 and then this bottom
section is going to be the current spec
okay so we're going to kind of focus on
the current spec because that's what ie
future versions of ie and browsers that
adopt
flexbox in the future will use
so first of all we set the display
property to flex so that's how we know
that we're going to manage our children
inside this lm element as flex elements
we then are going to decide whether
we're going to set it as a row or a
column so we can have our elements fall
in a row which means they're going to go
from left to right or in a column where
they're going to go to top to bottom we
also are going to have the option to
reverse that and we'll show that in a
minute
and then we're going to decide that it's
going to wrap or not
so what we've done with mrs brady we've
actually set a justify
to be the end which is basically going
to kind of cram all of the content into
the end of the flex box so in this case
it keeps her on the right side of the
screen
and also we're going to add an alignment
to her to keep her centered so we're
going to keep her centered into the
light the right and so we apply that to
the parent element and it applies those
controls to the child
next when we add in the girls we have
four boxes on the screens that are
different sizes and it's important to
remember that since we're managing the
parent not the children it can be any
element they can be all divs they can be
divs and images they can be a mixture of
whatever
and for this we have again our display
set to flex and then we're putting them
in columns because we wanted to go from
top to bottom
and then we're going to center align it
so it'll naturally flow from one column
to the next and everyone will be
centered aligned and have equal spacing
around each side
so when we introduce mr brady again we
have them set in a column and have him
centered but we have the justify set to
flex start so instead of kind of
bunching the elements to the end like we
had with the flex end for the justify
we're going to bunch into the beginning
and that's going to be the flex start
now adding the boys was actually a
little bit tricky
because what we wanted to do here is we
wanted to have one element
in a column of its own
and then the other elements in their own
column
so to do this
we had to add some additional css
to each of the child elements
otherwise if we
applied it as the css is on the screen
now
peter or excuse me greg the guy at the
top would be under mr brady because he
would want to flow in that column and he
wouldn't wrap onto the next column
so we added
an element to or excuse me a rule to mr
brady
where his order is a different number
than the rest of the boys so we set him
to be order of one
and by default all the boys are order of
zero which puts them into two different
groups
so i talked about how powerful flexbox
is you can actually change the order of
your elements even though they may be in
a
maybe out of a natural order that they
are in the dawn
so in this case we're going to group
them by setting orders to one and zero
and that means that the groups are going
to flow together which makes mr brady in
his own column and all the boys flow
together in the second column
now centering is
actually something that's been difficult
for us in css and everything that we've
done to try to get something to center
on the page has always been in my mind
borderline hackish to get it going but
flexbox actually has built into the spec
the ability to be able to center
something top to bottom left to right
and in this case we want one column
centered in the middle of the screen
with mrs brady and mr brady together so
we have the flex flow set to column
the alignment centered and then the
space the justified of the content to be
spaced around which just means it's
going to have equal space on both sides
so left and right is going to be the
same which puts it in the center of the
screen
so whenever we add all of the boxes on
the screen together
we're using a
wrap for the columns so it's going to
have three different columns on the
screen
and they're all going to be centered
which is going to give them an equal
amount of
spacing in between and it's going to go
from the first column wrap to the second
and wrap to the third
now when we think about
outside of our brady boxes the way that
we can implement this in real life we
really have some flexibility now what i
have here is the bing sports app this is
a windows 8 application that's written
in html5 and javascript okay that's one
of our platforms and what we're hearing
from our developers is that there is
actually more control and more
flexibility that they have when they use
css for their layout than when they use
manage code like xaml so css is actually
producing more flexibility for
developers so our apps our bing apps the
sports app our news app
finance are all written in html and use
css for styling and this is a beautiful
edge to edge layout that utilizes
flexbox and utilizes grids and a lot of
new css layout technologies to make
these beautiful
pages and they're flexible as well so
here we have columns with fonts and
texts that are different
and
interwoven pictures
with the articles all done with css
so flexbox is also great because when
you change the size of the screen you
can use your media queries to determine
how you want the layout to change so if
you have it in a wide column it may look
one way if you have it in a full screen
it may look another
so point up one more example here
so mixing
flex with media queries gives us a lot
of flexibility
to change without making any css
alterations to those elements so
depending on the width of the
the screen here
i choose the direction of the layout
whether it's being from left to right or
up to down
and also the order so i can set it to go
forward or reverse of that content
so see the css flexbox
still can be confusing it can still be a
lot to swallow and i'm sure that you're
not all going to be flexbox experts from
watching a few minutes of a presentation
here but i hope what you do take away
is that there's power in this we have a
lot of control over how our page is
gonna are gonna lay out and how each of
our users are going to see
the content that we want to provide for
them so i have a few resources here i'll
make sure that at the end i tweet out
these resources um some of these are
from chris mills over at opera who's
done a really great job of explaining
how to use flexbox in today's world if
you want to support the legacy versions
along with the modern versions
and then the microsoft implementation
and of course the
the spec itself from the w3c
so that's the content i had for today
i hope that you walk away
wanting to implement flexbox in your
applications as well
so
questions i have a few minutes for
questions
yes
so the question was are there any
performance concerns that you have to be
considered
considerate of whenever you're using
flexbox so flexbox being natively
controlled is actually going to perform
very well across browsers so if you're
using currently
heavily nested css or even javascript to
control some of your layouts css in
almost every case the flexbox is going
to perform better now it is important to
keep in mind that there is not
um full support it's it's a this is a
fairly new spec that's been introduced
and being adopted so when you do use it
in a web environment you need to be
concerned about your legacy browsers and
either using polyfills or falling back
to a different layout for browsers that
don't support it
yes so regions is
a great companion with flexbox the
question was have we used have we tried
adobe regions with the flexbox and
a lot of the layouts that i showed
inside of the bing apps are using
regions that allow your content to flow
from one container to another so it
gives you the ability to be able to
layout
use the high level elements using
flexbox and then let regions control how
much text ends up in each of those boxes
so it becomes a very natural companion
together
whenever you're trying to do some
creative layouts with text using flexbox
with regions
again gives you a lot of control over
your content
so
the question is
whenever you change the order of
elements
with css than they are in the dom or
their accessibility concerns
i would say there are accessibility
opportunities because a lot of times you
lay out
your html in a way that may be natural
for markup and generally natural for a
screen reader but if you want it to
appear different
for the visual needs that you have then
you introduce flexbox to change the
layout for that so if you are going to
um
if you're going to
use flexbox to change the order of your
dom
instead of
changing it
you know in your markup i guess if
you're doing it because you're lazy then
yes you need to be concerned for
accessibility but if you're doing it
because you actually need a difference
between what is being presented on the
page
and what the visual users are seeing
then it's actually an opportunity in my
eyes
i think that's it
[Applause]
you